foreign
[Music]
my name is Andreas sofans and today I'm
gonna talk about interactive multi-layer
maps in shiny with the leafdown package
for my talk I'm gonna use the meteostat
wettest record keyboard data set which
contains monthly measurements from over
2000 weather stations in the United
States which measure variables such as
the average temperature and
precipitation
and the question I want to discuss in my
talk is how can we most effectively
explore this data using insights into
how to solve common problems and
overcome the limitations of simple Maps
when we work with spatial data well it
is usually helpful to visualize the data
on a map because of the geographical
context and the intuitiveness that comes
with it so in this example we see the
average temperature per state and
already at the first glance it becomes
clear that the average temperature in
the South is higher than it is in the
North
however one phenomenon we often observe
when we aggregate data at higher levels
such as the state level is these
heartbreaks at the borders here it looks
like everywhere in California the
average temperature is quite high and as
soon as you take a single step into
Oregon the average temperature drops
significantly which is probably not the
case right
but the question is how can we explore
this in more detail or in other words
how can we zoom in
and one way to do this is to drill down
to see the data at a more detailed level
in this case at the county level in this
visually station we see that there's
indeed no heartbreaks at the state
borders but rather smooth transition and
that the overall height average
temperature of California is primarily
caused by the hot South
so you might wonder why we don't
aggregate the data directly then at the
county level and why do we even bother
to aggregate it at the state level in
the first place well let's have a look
at what happens when we plot the average
temperature for all the counties at once
in my opinion this looks quite cluttered
and the overall temperature trend is not
that easy to see especially when we
compare it to the state aggregation map
from before
I'd argue that it is much easier to see
on the right hand side that the average
temperature in the South is higher than
it is in the North
and this is one reason why it is really
important in many spatial data analysis
to switch between several aggregation
layers to be able to analyze both the
overall Trends as well as more Regional
trend
okay let's return to our map showing the
average temperature per County often we
are interested not only in one variable
at the given point in time but in
multiple variables and the relationship
or their development over time
so another question is how can we
visualize multiple variables
simultaneously using a map
and one approach to do this is to embed
the map in a shiny dashboard and connect
it to other dashboard elements like
charts or Tables by selecting the
regions of interest in the map we can
then display additional variables order
development over time in the other
dashboard elements in this case this
allows us to analyze the relationship
between the average temperature and
monthly precipitation as well as the
development of the average temperature
over time
but I don't want to just describe these
Solutions here I also want to tell you
that we have already implemented them in
the leafdown package with just a few
lines of code the leafton package
enables you to quickly create maps that
are embedded in a shiny dashboard and
have selectable regions which connects
the map to other dashboard elements
allowing you to visualize multiple
variables at once as well as the
development over time
they also have the drill down and drill
up functionality that allows you to
switch between several aggregation
layers such as from the state layer to
the county layer to analyze the data in
more detail
and these maps are not limited to only
two map layers instead we can drill all
the way down to the very individual
weather stations and compare their
measurements in the graphs as well
allowing the user to specifically select
the regions to drill down for avoids
unnecessary clutter and increases the
computational efficiency
so if you're now interested in quickly
creating such flexible and Powerful maps
by yourself I can highly recommend you
have a look at our leafdown package on
this slide I've provided the GitHub link
for you as well as the key facts and
features thank you very much for your
attention and have a great day
foreign
[Music]